[Applause]
[Music]
they just kept coming hundreds of people
filling the streets around the irish
parliament in dublin at vigils
nationwide they paused to express their
shock and anger at the murder of ashley
murphy well they're really sad as well
and that this has happened again and
this has happened to a young woman and
so so young and just starting out in her
life and doing something so ordinary and
and i think that everyone knows that
that could be them i want to be able to
go on a jog at four in the afternoon or
even at ten at night or midnight or
three in the morning or whatever like to
do just to be able to live without
worrying that some man is going to come
along and like end my life
ireland's prime minister anticipa martin
joined those remembering the young
school teacher some campaigners believe
the public response to her death could
signal a turning point for this country
this is basically about
the lack of respect the lack of care we
have for each other regardless of gender
we really do not
need to be in a country where gender
defines your level of fear and that's
what it is right now ashley murphy's
parents described their youngest child
as a special girl an angel and the rock
of their family the 23 year old was
attacked while jogging alongside the
grand canal in rural tullamore
police released their first suspect
sparking renewed fear but later said
they were making significant progress
there was there are huge parallels
between this and the murder of sarah
everard last year the young woman out in
her own um except it just happened in
the middle of the day it could have been
anybody at any time and i think people
are kind of people are a bit scared
particularly women are scared to go out
to go out on their own and and many
people will be thinking twice about
going going for that walk or going for
that run but that sense of fear has been
overtaken by another growing sentiment
that enough is enough
these people say they don't want to be
here marking the horrific murder of
another young woman but that they have
no choice that this needs to be the
watershed moment in the long campaign to
end violence against women church
leaders said this island could only
begin to consider itself civilized when
women can live free from fear
david blevins sky news in dublin